yeah almost nobody would argue with the
benefits of richer social environment in
which people have more options to
connect around all kinds of things the
key question is how do you still create
enough social cohesion on a level of a
country and increasingly also on the
level of the entire globe in order to
tackle our our main problems I mean we
need global cooperation like never
before
because we are facing unprecedented
global problems we just had Earth Day
and should be obvious to everybody we
cannot deal with the problems of the
environment of climate change except
through global cooperation similarly if
you think about the that is the
potential disruption caused by new
technologies like artificial
intelligence we need to find a mechanism
for global cooperation around issues
like how to prevent an AI arms race how
to prevent different countries racing to
build autonomous weapon systems and
killer robots and in weaponizing the
internet and weaponizing social networks
unless we have global cooperation we
can't stop that because every country
will say well we don't want to produce
killer robot it's a bad idea but we
can't allow our rivals to do it before
us so we must do it first and then you
have a race to the bottom similarly if
you think about the potential
disruptions to the job market and the
economy caused by AI and automation so
you know it quite obvious that there
will be jobs in the future but will they
be evenly distributed between different
parts of the world one of the potential
results of the AI revolution could be
the concentration of immense wealth in
some part of the world and the complete
bankrupt bankruptcy of other parts there
will be lot of new jobs for software
engineers in California but there will
be maybe no jobs for textile workers and
truck drivers in Honduras and Mexico so
what will they do if we don't find a
solution on the globe
like creating a global safety net to
protect humans against the shocks of AI
and enable them enabling them to use the
opportunities of AI then we will create
the most unequal economic situation that
ever existed it will be much worse even
than what happened in the Industrial
Revolution when some countries
industrialized most countries didn't and
the few industrial powers went on to
conquer and dominate and exploit all the
others so how do we create enough global
cooperation so that the enormous
benefits of AI on automation don't don't
go only stray to California and eastern
China while the rest of the world is
being left far behind yeah